oui prénom bande a gravi cary agos en
garrigues 6 mars car bien un pool
anglais
ca
piscine ici et du paraphe
on commence quand
c'est un combat contre la dose incolore
inodore invisible est partout autour de
toi tu respires m'en procure son vin la
soirée
peut expliquer ce revirement
ça fait quoi là d'autres
la peur est venue brouiller tu t'es qui
toi
et jambes qui tremblent
c'est ça la dose
le
souvent ça veut dire quoi pas souvent
je serai chiens ils sont ici que j'ai
des tonnes la prépa je ne connais pas je
te jure
ici on compte tout cela sur l'autre
comment se la jouer perso ça va pas le
faire mais je comprends pas ce que je te
dis c'est moche qui arriverait ton
équipe
de quoi tu parles tu m'as demandé
trouver des gamins et moi je vais faire
avec ce qu'ils avaient ça fait beaucoup
c'est simple là
notez en sursis
si on relève encore trop de tout sur ton
dosimètres on t'arrête pour la saison
ok moi ce que je veux rester ici